[Applause]
let me connect my computer now okay cool
I thanks for coming I'm Jonah so I work
at Columbia my primary work is on Stan
the probabilistic programming language
just a curiosity it's not the topic of
tonight's talk but are there people here
have used Stan or know what it is okay
cool
for those of you who don't although most
of you seem to like modeling language
for fitting statistical models that
interfaces with R and Python and other
platforms but I'm not gonna too much
about Stan tonight it's what was used to
fit the models that I'll show but the
point of my talk tonight mostly is to
talk about workflow and I'm gonna use
visualizations and pictures to try to
but the focus is really not on like you
know new fancy visualizations it's just
on the work flow and how you can use
visualizations to at each step in that
way to hopefully get a better grasp of
what's going on and fit better models I
think I mean some of the particular
models I'm going to talk about our
Bayesian models but a lot of the ideas
are more general in terms of the
workflow although if you're not using
Bayesian statistics you can kind of
ignore view of the view of the parts
that you'll find but otherwise I think
it'll be more broadly applicable or at
least I hope all right and please feel
free to interrupt with questions like
I'd rather talk about it in a moment but
then I'll also leave time at the end but
it's totally fine to ask a question in
the middle okay so I said it is I'm
mostly going to talk about workflow and
I'm going to talk about some steps in
this workload I think will be familiar
to
everybody in the room like sorry
[Music]
as you might know it
checking this is where and I'll go into
more detail where before we actually fit
a model using real data we can already
assess you know what type of data does
the model we're considering generate
right and think of it's consistent with
our domain knowledge and before we even
bother using the real data that we have
then you end up fitting the model
depending on what types of algorithms
you're using there's going to be
different sorts of Diagnostics hopefully
you're using algorithms that have
Diagnostics and so they'll be step in
your workflow where you're getting many
potentially many different models as a
in the Bayesian workflow what we would
do afterwards is actually you know check
the fit of those models and to do that
we would do something called posterior
predictive checking but there are
analogous steps where you're checking
the fit of your model it outside of
Bayesian statistics also and then
finally or at least finally for this
talk if we have time you might have many
models that you're considering you want
to find some way to compare them select
among them average them something like
that right and then the idea here would
be then to iterate on this process
honing in on kind of the most useful
thing that you can do for whatever
problem you're studying so it's not that
you would stop here often at some of
these steps you might identify things
that you really notice you want to make
changes to and then you don't have to
keep going you can kind of come back to
the beginning starting at any point and
go through and the idea is that you're
kind of moving towards whatever model or
collection of models you'll end up using
for the problem that you're working on
and so that's that's the workflow that
I'm going to talk about and I'll go into
detail at each step and show some
pictures and I'm gonna use one example
kind of running example throughout the
whole thing that is not from my area of
expertise and probably not most of yours
but I think is a good kind of simple
example to
to use and I will go through that next I
should give credit to my collaborators
on this and I'll make I'll share these
slides I think they share them through
the meetup page or something and so
these are links if you want the code for
making the stuff that you see or to read
the paper that we wrote on this topic so
I think those I'll check and make sure
those are the right winks when I share
the slides there but this is work with
dent Simpson aki veteran Michael
Betancourt and manager Gilman so
definitely not just me okay so the
example that we're going to use is
estimating the concentration of
particulate matter so a certain type of
air pollution and really small
particulate matter in this case
measuring less than 2.5 micrometers in
diameter and so this is we think we cite
some 4.2 some references in the paper
but this is a concern globally different
at two different degrees in different
parts of the world that's associated
with deaths of not just animals but also
humans that on a pretty large scale and
there's a problem which is that we only
have good data in certain parts of the
world so most of the data that is
collected on this and primarily I'm
going to be talking about data that's
used by like the World Health
Organization and other big bodies like
that come from satellite measurements
whereas ideally you have measurements
from ground monitors and so for the
purpose of this talk when I if I talk
about the actual concentration I'm
basically referring to like ground
monitor level we'll just kind of fish
there's some measurement error there but
I'm just going to kind of treat those as
known it's the satellite measurements
that tend to be very noisy right and
unfortunately the distribution of it
where we have the ground monitors in the
world not be rising to you they actually
tend to be I'll explain the not located
we think there's the highest the largest
problems so on this picture here the
black areas are where there are ground
monitors for measuring the
concentrations here and the darker pink
and purple areas are where there's the
biggest problem right so we have very
sparse coverage in Africa even though
there are really high concentrations in
northern Africa also parts of Asia but
most of the monitors are in North
America and Europe ok does that graph
makes sense ok so that's the problem
what we basically wanted the problem to
solve here is how can we use the ground
monitor measurements so for some
locations we have both satellite and
ground monitor measurements of the black
dots Ascenta can we use that information
to better calibrate the rest of the
satellite measurements where we don't
have ground monitor measurements right
and this is not a problem that I solved
or that we solved this is a problem that
other people were working on and we
decided to use it as an example to talk
about the work flow but there's a good
paper where they actually fit more
complicated models than will talk about
today and that's linked to in the paper
that associated this if you actually are
interested in this problem and want to
see what they're actually really doing
you can check that out I think the only
thing that I have to say about
exploratory data analysis that might not
be the most common thing that said there
like that might be new but probably not
the most people is that to think of it
as a step where you're already billed I
think I could say building a network of
models where you're ready using the
exploration to imagine models as opposed
to just saying okay what what features
of the data are there and so what I mean
by that is stuff that you've definitely
already seen when I say ok like there's
a linear trend here so what you're
looking at here is on the X
axis the satellite measurements or the
logarithm this is all going to be on the
log scale and then on the y-axis the
ground monitor measurements obviously
just for the locations where we have
both and the different colors are the
different regions the World Health
Organization groups the regions are all
geographical except for the high-income
region which is a combination of north
america and europe australia and you'll
see on the maps in a second and so if
you just plot these on a graph and I
think I just told GG plot to overlay a
regression line and the r-squared is
like point six or something like that
and it's actually a pretty decent linear
fit you can also notice immediately that
probably there's variation by region
here right and so that would be
something that you might notice in any
exploratory data analysis but I'm
thinking immediately when I noticed that
okay I'm probably gonna fit some sort of
multi-level model here where I'm
allowing for you know heterogeneity
across the regions and also going to
partially pull information to make up
for really small sample sizes in some of
the areas so I'm already kind of
imagining the models that I might fit
and so then I just made another plot
watch like first site I showed you the
World Health Organization region so the
the pink ones does this have a pointer
you can see that Australia like
Argentina and Chile and Western Europe
and North America are all considered one
region but then everything else is
geographically contiguous and we so if
you make the same plot as I made before
but you put a different line for each of
those regions you can see so these are
kind of like uncertainty bins and again
I'm not fitting well the technically
it's fitting models but I'm not really
fitting models here I'm just telling
ggplot don't like put the regression
lines here I'm just improvising a little
bit I'm not really in my model fitting
say
here I'm trying to look at what's going
on the data and so you can see the ones
with the larger uncertainty bands
they're gonna be from the regions where
we have less data points right or also
where we have more variation either one
and then but so some of the lines are
pretty precise some of them there's a
lot of uncertainty the slopes and the
intercepts are different now I might not
believe that it's true to this extreme
so we don't really know what the slope
and intercept of this line is for
example but there is evidence here that
I should think about fitting a more
complicated model than just a regular
linear regression or something so the
first thing we we did was we said well
why are we grouping countries in this
way and what we didn't start we didn't
do this but we had the idea to do this
based on some work by other people that
we linked to in the paper and so if you
yeah I want to show back up at the top
here so if you cluster countries based
on like you know past information about
what we know about the particulate
matter concentrations then you get a
different map right some parts of it are
similar we also get a different map
which means you have a different way of
grouping the countries to fit a model
and you'll learn something different if
you're right if you're estimating group
specific or country or region specific
effects or something like that and so
you'll probably learn something
different depending on how you group
these these countries and so you can see
that we get different lines right so
already I'm just kind of making quick
plots here but I'm already imagining
like three different models one is like
a simple linear regression that I don't
think is you know sorry I don't think
it's particularly useful you know the
one we saw here but I'm probably always
gonna fit the most simple model anyway
at least so I can then look at where it
does poorly and build it up and then
here you can imagine like two different
models where we have
where we have observations nested within
regions but the regions are defined
differently right it's kind of three
different models already any questions
and that's a par so that's nothing new I
think for them for the most part okay to
be if we have J different regions and n
measurements then this is the simple
linear regression model so just with the
all the variables on the log scale so we
have like one intercept and one slope
and that's the normal distribution and
so that's like a simple linear
regression model right here and then so
here's this notation okay for people
okay we use everybody uses different
notation so sometimes I get confused
myself and then the other two models are
the same except the slopes and the
intercepts they're gonna be allowed to
vary by region and the only difference
is how you define the the regions right
so we would have I'm gonna use mu here
just so I can then define it on the next
line where now we have some kind of
global intercept here alpha zero some
shift off of it for each of the J
regions all right
this gives us a unique intercept for
each of the regions and then we the same
thing for the slope where you have some
slope for some kind of global slope and
then a region specific deviation from
that right so far actually haven't
really said anything the Bayesian at all
right
so yeah in this particular model we're
assuming that the variances are the same
but you can generalize that to and in
fact I think they so the actual model
that ends up getting fit in the real
analysis of this that we didn't do is
like you know there's spatial
correlations and all sorts of stuff like
that but for the purpose of like
thinking about the workflow we just
stopped here but yeah you probably fit a
more complicated model than this
question any other questions
I'm a little short on the breadth - I'm
just getting over a cold I feel like I'm
panting okay okay right so we have so
these two terms are gonna combine for
the intercept and these for the slopes I
could have just ignored like gotten rid
of the alpha 0 and beta 0 and they
because they get it's the same for
everybody but I like thinking about it
as some global intercept and then a
shift for each of the regions ok but all
right we can take this a step further
and say we're gonna well it's I liked it
so we're gonna model the slopes and the
intercepts right we could have other
variables we don't in this particular
model we could have other variables that
help us learn about the slopes and the
intercepts but at a minimum we can give
them prior distributions and in some
sense we're not so here we're gonna say
that there that what we're gonna say
ahead of time is that they're centered
at 0 right in other words we could have
also dropped this alpha 0 term and stuck
it in there instead but the deviations
from the global slope and intercept are
centered at 0 and then there's some
amount of variability in this case tau
that sanger how different are these
intercepts
each other how different are the slopes
from each other how much are they
allowed to vary right so if tau alpha is
really big then the region intercepts
are allowed to be very different from
each other and if it's very small
they're gonna be very they're very
similar to each other and the same for
the slopes in the extreme I mean they
could be identical to each other right
but so this is what's gonna but the fact
that we're not fixing the value of tau
of the taos we need to put priors on to
Nate that means that we're gonna get
partial pooling in this model right the
towels are going to be informed by all
the data points the alphas correspond to
each region and the betas to each region
but the towels are common to all of them
so we're gonna learn something about the
variability that way which is gonna pull
the estimates of the alphas and the
beta's towards each other does that make
sense here so in other words for the
observations that we for the regions
where we don't have a lot of them all
right we're gonna be more suspicious of
the estimates that we get and we're
gonna want to use more information about
what we know globally right now there
and for the regions where we have a lot
of information right we can be more
confident about what we can learn just
from those data points
all right and that's pretty much true of
like every phenomenon uh I've ever
studied right that sorry that time
that's something like that is that is
the case right you have more information
on certain groups whatever group means
and what you're studying then on others
and you're gonna trust what you know
about the the groups they have more
information about and so if we just put
like well if we drop this entirely or
just fixed to these values we wouldn't
get that effect right we would just be
saying that the slopes and intercepts
are totally independent of each other
but here this links them to get
they all they're all dependent on Tao
which means that information if you put
through this out in a diagram right
you'd be able to connect all the
observations to Tao right maybe I should
have drawn that but uh and that's what's
going to give us the sharing of
information and you'll hear people face
a shrinkage or borrowing strength or a
partial pooling all right that makes
sense question about that topic
okay this is my favorite part of this
because because we get to just like
simulate data and but I think for a long
time I realized just how important this
step is this saves you a lot of time and
that is get to know the models that
you're going to that you're thinking
about fitting before you fit them and
you'll see what I mean in a second so if
if we use I'll say that if we use proper
but just imagine we're going to use
proper prior distributions here that
what we if you're gonna fit a Bayesian
model what you're really saying is that
I have some joint this probability
distribution over everything that's
observed and everything that's not
observed right all the data and all the
parameters or we say data and parameters
it's really more broad than that because
parameters gonna include like missing
data points and things like that
anything that's on them sir right and
you can write that either as like a
likelihood times a prior or a posterior
time's a marginal likelihood the middle
one is the one that's actually useful
often we're trying to find out the
things on the on the right hand side and
these we get the likelihood on the prior
we can actually specify alright and so
what this means because we have a joint
distribution over data and parameters if
we use a proper prior distribution this
model can simulate data itself I'll show
you what I mean by that I'm gonna skip
this
yes yeah so we have to disallow improper
priors because you can't sample from
something that's not a probability
distribution right but if we're not
using flat priors here then a Bayesian
model will be generative which means
that it describes a process by which
data can be generated and what and so
this is what I mean by that it's often
very hard to write down the whole data
generating mechanism right as one
function like what's the distribution
that right we can often I should say we
can write down pieces of what we want to
know and piece them together to get
something useful and those pieces are we
have some prior and so we could simulate
some value for our parameters I'm going
to call the particular value data star
so we get just say R we have a normal
distribution that's our prior we just
sample a value from that distribution
all right and then we have a likelihood
which could be whatever maybe it's a
Poisson distribution in the case of the
particular matter example it's also a
normal distribution and we can simulate
observations Y star data points from
that right so with this two-step process
you draw a value from the prior plug it
in to the in this case the data
distribution right the distribution
that's generating the actual
measurements and from that together it's
as if we drew data points from the full
data generating mechanism right but we
often don't know how to write down this
P of Y but we do well it's not that we
know the other parts but we can choose
the other parts right and and to do this
this is the same process that we'll talk
about with posterior predictive checking
but here instead of plugging in instead
of using like actual data points we're
just generating them
right generating them using draws from
the prior first as opposed to like
learning those right from the actual
observations and then simulating data
points using the posterior of data or
something that's what we'll do later so
but but I just want to emphasize again
at no point here have we used have we
can have we actually like plugged in the
data points that we'll end up using it
at the model we've simulated data points
that if our model is worth fitting
should be somewhat consistent with our
knowledge of whatever we're studying
right and so what the point is that if
you pick and these are just some like
kind of standard non informative priors
that you might see in like a literature
here I'm using a normal distribution
with standard deviation not variance but
it doesn't really matter what you pick
here but like you know vague priors that
don't really convey any domain knowledge
if we think about our particular matter
example so on the x-axis of this plot
are the ground monitor measurements like
the full set of them not differentiating
by region just a full plot and on the
y-axis is our data point simulated using
these priors for some of the parameters
plugging them in to the next the normal
distribution for the generating the data
points and then I plot them and they are
kind of ridiculous right so we have like
multiple orders of magnitude difference
and we're on the log scale here now I'm
not suggesting that you should always
compare to your observed data at this
point but since we're not all experts in
particulate matter it's helpful to look
at that but if you're actually studying
a problem you don't need to at this
point use your actual data and make this
explicit comparison you should be able
to make these simulations look at the
on their own and say that's totally
inconsistent with with my domain
expertise or something right with my
prior knowledge but in this case it's
nice so look at them both because we're
not the people who would actually be
doing an analysis of particulate matter
but right so if we were to use priors
like that right so that we haven't used
our data yet right so if we were to use
priors like that then what would that
right how could we get useful results
using priors like that if the
simulations of the data that we're
getting are so ridiculous we could but
really only if we had data that was
informative enough to totally wipe out
the effect of the prior distribution
right and particularly when we're
fitting like a hierarchical model like
this well we already know in this case
that we have noisy data so that's
probably not going to work but well even
if you have a lot of data that doesn't
mean that you have incredibly
informative data right it's not about
the number of data points necessarily
and especially then if you're slicing it
up and fitting models that are dividing
I don't know people into subgroups or
products into other groups and you're
making smaller and smaller groups
defined by more variables then your data
actually becomes pretty sparse right if
you're trying to answer any particular
kind of fine-grain question there right
and so people didn't used to like care
about this right like this idea that you
should i mean people used to even use i
don't know if they're there for a long
time people didn't really ask well what
happens if is the data that i get if i
simulate from the prior distribution and
plug it in at all consistent
with with what we know but I think more
and more this is becoming common
practice in a particularly subset of
Bayesian statistics but I think the
principle can be applied regardless of
if you're doing Bayesian work or
otherwise just to please like to assess
the implications of your model right you
don't need your actual data to do that
right and then why bother fitting that
model if it's already totally
implausible right unless you want to
just learn from it so if we do I'm not
even so if we do something more
reasonable which is to say let's you
know if you talk to people who study
this kind of a particulate matter
problem they'll tell you well the
satellite measurements are noisy but
like we would tend to think that they're
not necessarily particularly biased
maybe a good a good prior at least is
that like a slope of zero sorry an
intercept of 0 and a slope of 1 or
something like that as a prior but then
allow for a you know to be wrong at
least an amount of variation around that
around that wine and so these are just
the priors on the global intercept in
the global slope right so an intercept
of centered at zero slope centered at
one these are the positive half half
normal distributions you could use some
other distribution there just for
simplicity you just need some sort of
positive only distribution on the
standard deviations of the intercepts
and slopes that decays relatively
quickly and now remember we're on the
log scale here like so the actual
measurements might be kinda like what
we're dealing with
pretty small numbers actually here so
these ones and like the standard
deviation of one is actually pretty big
in in fact we'll see these are actually
pretty weak priors still in this case
right so what's this might be a highly
informative prior and a different
problem and be totally under
unreasonable or reason why I don't know
but in this case here's what you get if
you simulate so again we have the actual
ground monitor measurements on the
x-axis just as a reference point because
we're not experts in particular matter
on the y-axis we have the simulations
that you get if you use these priors
again but you could use some something
just that has a similar effect you don't
use these exact numbers right and then
there's the next level of Prior that's
on the intercepts they intercept some
slopes where these values are just
getting plugged in and you get data like
that where and again on the log scale
being kind of twice as high up here this
is over there is pretty big difference
you can see that these these data these
simulations are actually and then if
you're you are a domain expert you'd say
okay well some of these simulations are
actually consistent with like states of
the world that are not possible given
that light continues or something like
that right particularly these
simulations like once you get up here
once you get actually I think not
pictured on the y-axis because it's too
small is like the log density of like a
neutron star which is like 60 or
something I don't know right like so
these are consistent with like no
possible life on earth or anything like
that right but even even some of these
are too but again but this is much more
reasonable and if you were an expert on
this problem you wouldn't need to
compare it necessarily to your actual
observations you just be able to say
okay well this prior data generating
process covers like all plausible data
sets that are consistent with our
knowledge right it goes beyond that so
maybe you're at this is like a
conservative prior to use to say I'm
still allowing for data sets that I
don't think are possible but I'm not
allowing I'm not wasting computation I'm
not allowing my inferences to be
affected by attempt by putting prior
weight on things that are totally
inconsistent with our experience of the
world right and it does matter right
you're you're gonna waste computation
time if your data isn't super
informative then you're gonna need to
make you're gonna need to craft a prior
distribution that at least
constrains your inferences somewhat here
and so if you put them on the same graph
the more reasonable ones basically look
like a line because they can't even fit
on the screen all right so that would be
builds of those two simulations here and
so again we haven't used well we have
used some of our actual measurements
just to give ourselves a reference point
but if you were actually doing this
analysis you wouldn't have needed to use
your actual data points to get this far
all right and so just to just to put
this more into to context so this is
right so this is the system where you're
essentially examining your own plan in
some sense look I have these models that
I'm thinking about fitting are they
already before I fit them worth using
right and I think that's an important
question to keep asking I'm going to
I actually jump ahead to I mean I'll
include all that stuff here in those
those slides here but the important one
here so then you write some we we're
gonna we fit these models so we fit the
three models that I talked about in the
earlier slides we used to stand and MCMC
and some of the previous slides are some
diagnostic plots but but the most
interesting piece here is to then do the
same thing that we did with the prior
predictive checks but this time instead
of simulating from the priors and then
plugging them in to the distribution for
generating measurements we're going to
use simulations from the posterior
distribution from what we've learned
about all the unobserved quantities and
the model conditional on the data that
we've actually fed in so now we've said
okay we're not using the prior anymore
but the process is going to be exactly
the same we're gonna do exactly the same
thing but at the step where we sample
the value from the prior we're going to
take it from the posterior distribution
and what that gives you if you do that
to say process again is the posterior
predictive distribution which is
essentially the probability distribution
for that you would use to predict
observations new observations sorry so
the process here is exactly the same the
only different part here is that now
this distribution is conditional on the
actual data so if you run stand or
something like that these would just be
the samples of your parameters that you
get or you run any MCMC algorithm were
approximating imprints algorithm that
then can generate samples or something
like that and then again we plug in to
the same distribution as before the
particular matter case it's a normal
distribution we're saying that the log
of the
particulate matter is normally
distributed but whatever distribution it
is here binomial Poisson whatever you're
doing the same exact thing as you did in
the prior predictive checking section
but just using samples from the
posterior and what that gives you is
samples from the posterior predictive
distribution the difference between this
distribution and the one in the prior
predictive checking is that that wasn't
conditional on the observed Y the
squiggle here I meant to use star sorry
Y star or Y square something some new
data point right we're getting now we
get samples from the distribution of
what our model predicts all right after
learning from the data and so here we
actually make all sorts of different
visualizations that are going to help
and these might some of these might be
familiar to some of you some of them
won't be but so here we can compare and
we can simulate where we get to simulate
as many we can simulate as many data
sets as we want sample we draw from the
posterior and could then be plugged in
and give us a whole new data set right
so we can actually let if we could
actually let's say we take I don't know
5,000 samples from the posterior
distribution for each one of those we
could do this two step process and
simulate a whole data set and so we
could actually get 5000 simulated data
sets right so each one I mean say that
again
so each I should have some of this here
the theta in the particular matter
example theta are all the slopes
intercepts everything like that the
error standard deviation Sigma right
everything that we don't know and we're
trying to estimate and and then the Y
are gonna be some are gonna be log
particular matter concentrations right
and so each each theta so each set of
each intercept that we draw from the
posterior distribution right we could
simulate a whole set of Y values a whole
set of measurements the same size as our
actual data set right but then we're
gonna simulate like five thousand slopes
and intercepts or something like that so
for each one of those we could simulate
a whole data set of particulate matter
values so then we can start making
visualizations about what's the
distribution of those simulated data
sets and so here now we can say how well
does it fit the data right so what
you're seeing here is a comparison the
dark lines are like kernel density
estimates of like the actual data set
the particular observations and then
these kind of shaded areas are actually
like a couple hundred thin lines then
Colonel dent it each one a different
predictive just different sample from
the predictive distribution you use span
or something like that you would you
could generate these in the are the
points that are used in like the
generated quantities block or something
right this is taking the kernel density
estimates of a bunch of predictions and
you can see so here this is like a Mart
we're looking at the whole at whole data
set distribution is here you can see the
difference in
fit between the multi-level model and
the single level model we don't
necessarily want to capture every little
bit of noise here in the data right
which might be a sign of overfitting but
we want at least a decent fit to the
data otherwise why are we using this
model we can look at other things for
each of the predicted predictive data
sets the simulation we could calculate
like the skew of that distribution if
that's something that you essentially
whatever you're interested in in the
problem that you're working on you might
be interested in how much variability
there is in the predictions or what the
means are or whatever it is that you're
interested in you can look at for each
of the simulations and so these
histograms are made by calculating the
skewness of you know each data set that
I've simulated and then the vertical bar
is like the empirical value of if I
calculated it with the actual data okay
so this is a comparison of the
predictions that my model or the
properties of the predictions that my
model is making and be the same
statistic calculated on the observed
data and again we don't necessarily need
to always get it exactly right but it
should be plausible right we're not
looking to capture every bit of noise in
the actual data but we want our
predictions to be consistent with the
data that we've observed
right and then you can do the same thing
at a more fine-grained level so this is
by region right and again we fit three
models but I'm just doing comparisons
between some of them one multi-level
model and one single level model whereas
now each of these little histograms is
for a different region and then we're
looking at the median of the predictions
just different examples and the idea is
not that any one of these comparisons is
necessarily useful to in every case but
you think about what are the things are
important in what you're working on and
then right so maybe you care about the
median but you don't care about
something else so you could look at you
might care I don't know what are the
most extreme but like how extreme are
they like the predictions that I tend to
get if you're working in some area where
you care about like you know what
percentage of the time am I getting an
observation bigger than some value or
something like that like anything you
can count anything that you can any
function that you pass in like a vector
of observations and it returns a single
number right can be used in this case so
you know you can calculate me and
standard deviations variances excuse my
asking this whatever you make up some
arbitrary thing whatever thing you care
about you can look at it value you over
all of the simulations in your posterior
predictive distribution and then you get
a sense of so this is giving us a sense
of the uncertainty that we have like if
you just look at the underlying
histograms that gives you a sense of
well how much I'm certain do we do we
have when predicting the median for this
group right if you're predicting new
data so this is like comparing to the
existing data points but then you might
want to make out-of-sample predictions
then you can't overlay the thick
vertical bar which is calculated from
the existing measurements but you still
you could make the same histograms and
summarize your uncertainty and
predicting different aspects of the
whatever variable you're in this case
it's the particular log concentration a
particular matter but it could be the
number of products sold or something it
doesn't it doesn't matter stop in a
second so the slides go further into
model comparison and stuff like that but
I guess to focus on the thank you I'll
share these slides and they talk about
other visualizations that you can make
to compare models that are also linked
to sources that explain are there links
yes okay that explain the plots but for
example just the types of visualizations
that you can make when you're comparing
models right these are actually
comparing the two different multi-level
models we've calculated something called
the expected log predictive density it
for this purpose is here you can just
think about it as measuring like how
surprising each data point is to the
particular model right
and then we're kind of different seeing
them here and you can see that
essentially whether or not we're below 0
or above 0 saying one of the models if
the data point is more consistent with
one of the models than the other right
and we can look at that for each of the
different data points so I've colored
them by region here and so we might not
say ok one model is better than the
other we might be able to say if we're
interested in this predictive task this
model is better but if we're interested
in a different task this other model is
better right there might not be one
answer at least here it looks like one
of the models kind of dominates in a few
areas but then they're pretty consistent
in all their areas right so you can look
at predictive measures like that
summarize predictive performance on the
whole data set and like collapse this
also like one number or something or you
can look at it point wise and
Zaman differences and how the models do
different ways that you can subset your
observations and this is just a visual
example of that of course they're just
numbers underlying this see you don't
have to meet the plot I think it's
helpful here I labeled this as Mongolia
turns out that so we look at this plot
and then we say wow why is one of the
models doing like so much better on
Mongolia than the other well it's
because like it's in I think it's in a
different I think it's in a different
region in the two models that we're
comparing here right because the regions
are defined differently and also there's
only one observation from Mongolia so
it's just a weird a weird data point if
we didn't know that in advance we look
at this plot we immediately say okay we
should probably look into that data
point sometimes I make a plot like this
and it turns out that there's some
coding error I'm seriously that I see a
plot like this and say these models
shouldn't be so different on this data
point it actually turns out that there's
been some data entry issue or something
like that or really there is a
difference that makes more sense in
terms of why there's a different thing
but you'd be surprised all the things
you can find out by just by making a
plot and saying what which data point is
that and so let me go
sorry to the last slide the plot in this
all the slides are you can make them all
using this base plot our package and all
the code is it's online but I'm I don't
think they're necessarily the most
beautiful visualizations in the world
they're not anything new but but just
the idea of like looking at scatter
plots of simulations from the predictive
distribution I don't know I'd be
surprised if you could find any papers
with the head in it until maybe like the
past like a couple of years or something
like that it's very and I think the more
that we do these things in like
visualizations the more likely it'll be
that people will look at them and think
about it as opposed to getting buried
away but but mostly these aren't
necessarily things like pictures that I
mean I I do encourage you if you're
publishing stuff to always show like the
checks that you're doing but even
especially for people working in
industry some workflow I think the
biggest takeaway from this is that like
at each step of that workflow there's
ways to be refining what you're doing
and you don't always need for example
you can learn it you can learn it so
much of and save so much so many
resources just by simulating data right
and saying worth considering all these
models because they're just a priori
ridiculous and that's often what happens
when I do like consulting something like
that I'll come in and just say have you
checked what kinds of data these models
are actually capable of simulating and
the answer is almost invariably no it's
just because that's not taught and but I
think it'll save you a lot of a lot of
time and headaches and they'll save you
trying to diagnose all sorts of problems
after you fit the models so much easier
to figure it out ahead of time than it
is to figure out why it's not fitting
well after you put it
and so there was more stuff in here than
I got to but and I want to leave some
time for questions and sorry I was
talking quickly
[Music]
sorry question any lingering questions
yes yeah we fit the models and stuff in
stand but but all of the prior
predictive simulations I just did them
in our right you don't you only need
something like Stan to actually fit the
model but you can but everything else is
just you could do it in our Python
whatever just the prior predicted stuff
to fit the multi-level models and stuff
yeah the default like Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo no u-turn sampler very nice and
stand but I mean these models weren't
particularly complicated you could
probably fit them in many different
software yeah yes sure you mean it's
like you asked so if you actually have
data points from a prior data generating
process yeah I think it's always worth
simulating data in particular because so
so this that are going on there's like
there's different ways in which the
model can be there's different ways in
which you can evaluate the model so the
reason to simulate data always is that
at a minimum the model should be fitting
data that it itself alright right so in
other words if I simulate data from the
model that I like I mean I fit the model
to that data and it doesn't fit then
there's something the code or I don't
know there's something like and it's
always worth doing something like that I
think so at a minimum you can always
simulate data from your model as like a
consistency check that right field data
fit the model data and basically recover
the parameter values that were used in
that simulation to some degree depending
on how many data points sound noisy the
data is more or less able to actually
recover those values and you probably
need to do it many times if you want to
actually take anything away from that
but but that's something you can always
do right if you use proper priors you
can always simulate data from the model
and Andrew Gelman and some other people
have a paper it's called simulation
based algorithm calibration something
like that it's on published but it's
definitely on archive that talks about
that procedure more formally basically
using simulating data from models and
refitting the models to those data many
many times in order to do like a
self-consistent
right it should should that should work
if it doesn't and there's something
wrong but yeah you can also I mean it's
always useful to have actual previous
data to use also but I wouldn't say it
ever rolls out the utility of simulating
yeah well sure yeah you can't really
compare it to the observed values in
that case yeah it's that's harder you
can't directly check I can't say well
how well am I predicting the latent
variables not something you can say but
you can better sense I I don't know I
mean one thing you can always do is say
how well is it predicting the
consequences of the Liam variables right
you can't I mean you're gonna get
predictive distributions for the latent
variables if you're actually modeling
them but you won't be able to compare it
to the observed values necessarily but
but there should be some implications of
the leading they connect to the
observables right and so yeah you only
actual posterior predictive checks you
can do is if you have observed like with
some thing that's measurable right not
in the in the sense that you can
actually observe it but yeah it's I
don't know look at you you have to
compare to the things that you actually
can observe but different ways of
modeling the latent variables will
result in different predictions for the
actual observables and so then you can
differentiate between them in that way
at least and you can also compare
directly how the predicted distributions
of latent variables that different
models make and see which is more
consistent with whatever Theory you're
working with or something like that so
you have to kind of come at that
question a little differently either
look at the consequences the observable
consequences of them or like how
consistent those distributions are with
what you know from other information
hopefully that makes some sense but yeah
I don't have any tricks for making them
not late and anymore
so yeah I didn't get to some of the
stuff in here just this but if you're
interested in like the MCMC diagnostic
visualizations and stuff like that those
are all in the so in the vignettes for
the base pod package it goes through
basically what I was gonna probably say
today about those visualizations so you
can actually read it and and it will be
make more sense than I wrote it so it'll
make more sense than me just here
speaking that's why that was the section
I chose to skip so yeah if that does
interest you you can read there and
thank you
[Applause]